це Дрон мінер для дистанційного
замінування російських позицій його
створили два куми волонтери з
івано-франківщини як виникла ідея
подзвонили з передової знайомі і кажуть
Танчик приїжджає з тої сторони і по
наших позиціях відстрілюються кожен
кожен день в той же самий час тоже саме
місце Отже до кілометра від нас ми
бачимо а зробити достати нема чим
послали мінера каже мінера пішов не
вернувся Колеса від гіроскутера шини від
дитячого квадроцикла інші деталі з
інтернету у звичайному гаражі чоловіки
розробили цей наземний Дрон вагою 40
кілограмів який за хвилину може
перевести мінну на 100 метрів і подолати
перешкоди на своєму шляху а завдяки
системі скидують цей мінер став
багаторазовим систем у рогатки - це
придумав кум закладаєш міну магніт чіп
приїхав на позицію
Міна вилетіла
усе це володимир з Романом роблять у
свій вільний час кримінувальника вони
створили назенний Дрон для евакуації
поранених і велодром для підвезення
постачання їх вже використовують
військові на передовій
А тепер Куми працюють над новими
пристроями для село борони основою під
кулемет та глушилками для Дронів та для
усього цього Їм потрібне фінансування
з кумом в нас фактично ідея виникають
весь час дуже багато ідей ну часто нема
або грошей або вільних рук всьо дві в
нас великий проблеми Ми хочемо щоб він
зробив наскільки роботу щоб ми знали що
він завізмінний на тих мінах зірвався
там
російський Федерації і
щоб нас побачила керівництво хоча б
Валерій Федорович хоча би хоча би там
нам лайк поставив знаєте І от хотів ще
Хотілося би нас побачили розумієте аби
хотя би трошки в нас щось влили аби Ми
дальше продовжували це робити отака наша
мрія
так само з квартири у Харкові почалася
розробка ударного безпілотника шуліка
мк-6 після початку повномасштабного
вторгнення Євгеній допомагав ЗСУ а потім
із партнером почав займатися військовими
розробками для армії Ми почали будувати
продукт перший фактично наш ударність
БПЛА ударного типу виплава шуліка тоді
він ще називався Джура джураєнка 6 і ми
його планували як
цивільного призначення Дрон який
буде використовуватися як Дрон і на
нього будуть там ставитися якісь корисні
навантаження системи скриду там і так
далі потім ми пішли вже в бік того що
почали робити системи захищеного зв'язку
GPS там камери специфічні термальні і
система корисного навантаження цей Дрон
призначений і скидати фугас на
акумулятивні снаряди і вражати техніку
та особовий склад противника вночі він
дуже швидкий та легкий у користуванні
йому потрібно всього 5 хвилин щоб він
влетів І ще плюс дві хвилини щоб він
долетів система скидування розрахована
на 4 снаряди вона почергової скидає
тобто Пілот після кожного скиду може
робити поправки повітру або там по ще
якимось мовам і цей йому дозволяє більш
точно скидати тобто якщо ми кидаємо там
перші снаряд бачимо що ми 3 м від цілі
то на другі кидаємо чітко в ціль А я вам
скажу трьох снарядів вистачить щоб там
нормально єдине робить усі модулі за
потреби можна легко замінити а замість
Великого наземного комплекса пульт
дистанційного керування і свій модуль
зв'язку 6 версії X може летіти від семи
до 10 кілометрів
або якщо це політ по часу То це близько
30 хвилин
має захищений радіо та телеметричний
канал
захищений модуль зв'язку дженссос тобто
GPS і відеосигнал має камеру
термальну тільки термальну на цьому
дроні Можливо ще опція термальна плюс
ДНК це двох сенсорна камера яку в
принципі теж можна поставити на цей же
на цю ж систему
працює на висоті від 1050 до
250 десь метрів це стабільна висота для
роботи з такою камерою
точність влучання чи кучність влучання
близько одного тире двох квадратних
метрів з висоти 150
метрів а сам Дрон досить рибостійкий Ми
дуже сильно заморачувались на зв'язком
ну тобто навіть якщо те що ви говорили
про реп навіть якщо нам вибивають
супутники
Пілот може вручну тримати Дрон
позиціонувати його і довести його назад
Або прийняти рішення продовжити місію
третій блок нашої розробки це дженеси
сприймач який ми прошиваємо самі і
робимо фільтр який відслідковує за
давлення gps-сигналу тобто якщо ми якщо
Дрон відчуває
задавлені джинсовий сигналу то програмне
забезпечення яке на борту нашого
ресівера відслідковує це і перемикає на
інший діапазон тобто антена підтримує 5
діапазонів і будь-який з цих п'яти
діапазонів повинен працювати якщо все ж
таки станції Так що всі п'ять діапазонів
заглушать то звичайно там Дрон не зможе
орієнтуватися в просторі у компанії
кажуть готові працювати і постачати
сотні таких ударних Дронів на передову
лише б були кошти та замовлення від
держави зараз компанія подала документи
на сертифікацію Дронів і в подальшому
прагне отримати оборонне замовлення та
для цього треба пройти 10 кіл
бюрократичного пекла кажуть розробники
мета щоб у військових не було головного
болю відносно того що збирати кошти щоб
держава закупила сотні тисяч і це
військові частини просто потрапило тому
що зараз замість того щоб команда
скайлаб думала про продукт Про
вдосконалення про
рендістаді про якісь блоки про
випробування щоб їздила за кордон
спілкувалась з
військовими які мають ліпші системи
зв'язку дженнесист так далі і держава
була спроможна закупити Це все ми
поставили це масово поставив і серійно
ми б змогли
задовольнити
150 плюс на рік
державу а саме військових Дронов шуліка
спростити цей процес взявся кластер
брейван перший клас це для розвитку
технології в оборонній галузі державний
проєкт заснований ним цифри Міноборони
генштабом РНБО мінекономіки Та
мінзстрадахпром це платформа покликана
об'єднати розробники військових
технологій із компаніями державою та
армією щоб ці розробки якомога швидше
могли з'явитися на полі бою Сьогодні
держава зацікавлена в тому щоб таких
оборонних технологій їх з'являлися дуже
багато тому ми розуміємо що ці гроші
якраз допомагають виробникам або зробити
Перше Прототип його протистувати до там
довести його і ефективність і далі після
цього легше вже всім або знов-таки
особливо коли вже є там допис до
експлуатації є підтвердження це
документально то тоді вже простіше
набагато і ти з цим виробником до
міністра техпрому і з ними говорити про
масштабування або з ними йти до інших
великих виробників які шукають собі там
партнерів Або шукати інших просто
виробничих потужностей для масштабування
там цього продукту це вже не питання
тобто історія в тому що цей грант має
допомогти зробити перший MVP який
продемонструє свою ефективність які там
буде погоджений буде затверджено там
генеральним штабом та Міноборони там
силами безпеки оборони компанія skylab
подалася і виграла грант на 25 тисяч
доларів але ця сума крапля в морі кажуть
розробники адже створення одного
винаходу обійшлося їм у десятки разів
дорожче ці гроші нам потрібні для однієї
мотиви Ми хочемо замінити деякі модулі
наприклад там модулі gns приймача на
інші вони стоять гроші тобто і ці модулі
вже військового призначення а не
цивільного який ми доробляємо як ми
пишемо прошивку і самі робимо а ці
модулі вже пройшли перевірку там в
країнах Альянсу Ми хочемо поставити ці
модулі і спробувати використати Дрон на
більш потужному Ребі на якому зараз адже
несе сприймач не отримує на грант може
податися будь-яка людина стартап чи
компанія яка розробила зброю чи техніку
для армії там розробка отримає військову
експертизу від генштабу генштаб визначив
12 пріоритетних напрямків система
розвідки артилерія розмінування
управління боєм медичне забезпечення та
інші серед них два основних наземні
роботизовані комплекси і Реп та реп
системи зв'язку фокус це наземні роботи
на це є великий запит на цей велика
потреба ми бачимо вже сьогодні у нас на
платформі там три з половиною місяці
проекту Сьогодні
зареєструвалася У нас вже більше 400
команд і серед тих команд 70 команд які
безпосередньо розробляють
нрк і нас вже перші такі комплекси
проходять допуск до експлуатацію
кодифікації НАТО тобто вони вже можуть
дуже швидкості дивитися на лінії фронту
їх там вже дуже чекають і друга історія
- це все що стосується реп і систем
зв'язків тому що це знов-таки це
по-перше захист це і захист наших людей
і це умовно кажучи захист наших Дронів і
нашої техніки яка летить на ту сторону
Крім того ми знаємо що ворог насправді
вони дуже потужні є своїх системах реп
добре знається на радіоелектронній
боротьбі компанія піраньятех яка ще з
2014 року займається системами
пригнічення зв'язку вони розробили
потужні антидронові рушниці комплекси
для захисту техніки та установки для
пригнічення безпілотників а купують їхнє
обладнання у 25 країнах світу в даному
випадку це так званий прилад для
створення
купола за рахунок е-е кругових антен
вертикальний поляризації
він може працювати як з рушницею такою
так може працювати з антенами це одна із
версій такої самої рушниці просто в
менших розмірах сам блок та рушниця так
само може працювати з такими ж самими
антенами без рушниці коли вона їде можна
поставити цей рюкзак в машину і буде
створений купол який дозволить зменшити
втрати відродив там із кедів 150-200
метрів
одразу тесту як вона працює зараз
включаємо рушницю коли ми розуміємо що
єдрон або ми його бачимо
включаємо
антидронну рушницю включається програма
перевіряє готовність каналів Після цього
ми включаємо подавлення якщо включаємо
подавлення навігації подавлення там
частоти на яких літають їх піввідрони
так що також вже тут працює і 2,4 і
п'ятірка і чекаємо дивимося де може бути
Дрон для того щоб відпрацювати закрити
йому навігацію і управління оскільки
жарко вентилятори вже працюють тобто
вони охолоджують систему вона не
нагрівається
[музика]
там знаходиться Дрон його видно дія
рушниці спрямована для переривання
зв’язку дрона з оператором щоб він не
міг коригувати чи наводити вогонь
супутників зникли керування 3.e
GPS втратили
керування Поки що є
тобто зараз було придушення каналів
керування GPS
завдяки чому Пілот втрачає
спочатку орієнтацію по супутниках а
потім втрачає канали керування тобто в
Дрон приходе в режим повернення додому
якщо вона є таке налаштування або просто
зависає на місці от тому що на фронті
наприклад не використовується така
функція і зачастує ну тобто від Дрон
зависає і потім з часом знизуються вниз
і просто завдяки тому що розряджається
акумулятор втрачається А ось такі великі
системи
здатніки це мобільна система яка працює
ну в рамках батальйону бригади Тобто
вона працює на дальностях Там до 20 км і
вона працює в основному по безпілотних
літальних апаратах от Це її основна
функція тому вона використовується для
перекриття повітряного простору від
великих БПЛА в орланів ну такого типу
уставляють в Україні
додаткові легко можуть користуватися і
ремонтувати таку техніку та фактично їх
замовлень від держави поки немає
фактично як замовлень це коли
Міністерство оборони напряму
заключає договір і закупляє то
обладнання яке її необхідне на
сьогоднішній день поки що потреба не
сформована Тобто нема потреби немає
замовлення немає коштів Тобто всі
фактичні закупівлі радіоелектронного
обладнання Скажімо так
60%, чи може 70 тому що є там компанія
які все-таки до війни там
стали на озброєння і в них є там
державне замовлення все всі інші але я
так розумію його не зовсім вистачає всі
інші
що включилися в цю роботу фактично Вони
працюють на власних коштах
розробники сподіваються що зі створення
м дальше зрозуміти бо треба Міноборони
отримати оборонне замовлення та
фінансування на нові покращені взірці та
їхнє Випробування Так звичайно там поки
що невеликі Суми говорять про те що є
якісь інвестори які готові будуть потім
вкладати кошти в тих взірці які пройдуть
випробування в міністерстві оборони Ну
будемо надіятись що це правда адже
основна мета кожного із допомогти армії
та пришвидшити перемогу України